- Les touristes reprennent
tranquillement leurs droits
au centre-viicicicicicicicicici,
mais attendues depuis longtemps
par l'stststrie touristique.
Et pour s'assurer que
les affaires reprennent,
l'industrie attendait aussi
des assouplissements
aux mesures sanitaires.
Affaires intergouvernementales
- Aujourd'hui, nous pouvons
annoncer des ajustements
à nos mesures sanitaires
parce que les Canadiens se sont
- À comptere e e e e e e e e e é
pour prendre un avion
ou train adadadada.
d'attente dans les aéroports,
Ottawa met fin à l'oioioioion
vaccinale pour tous ceux
qui y travaillent.
- Et nous allons maintenir comme
il se doit les mesures pour
les voyageurs internationaux.
- Cela veut dire que deux doses
de vaccin seront toujours
exigées pour franchir
la frontière. Même chose
à la maisonuououououoi une
quarantaine leur sera imposée.
JEAN-YVES DUCLOS,
ministre fononononononononononoé
publique, d'une mesure à la fois
effipepepepepeu coûteuse.
- L'Association du transport
aérien du Canada se réjouit, M n
du transport aérien du Canada- s
tout le monde, tous nos
partenaires économiques. Oui,
encore en retard en ce qui a
trait au mandat pour le masque.
lelelelelelelelelelelelelelelele
si... si les cas remontent,oror.
- Dans cette agence de voyage
aussi, la prudence est de mise,
tout comme
MARIE PIER GUILMETTE,
Inspirgegegegegeges
- C'est des bonnes nouvelles,
mais d'un autre côté,
je c c c c c c c c c c c c c c é
de savoir de voyager
g g g g g gens qui étaient
vaccinés comme eux.
- Dans les avions, c'est très...
la proximité, elle est là,
alors  il faut... On prendra
- Le gouvernement suspend aussi
l'obliédédédédédédédédédédédédée
moment. Et si la mesure devait
trtrtrtrtrtrtroduite à l'automn,
Ottawa précise que deux doses
de vaccins, ce ne serait pas
suffisant pour être considéré
adéquatement vacci
Radio-Canada, Ottaw